[Musique]
o o salut à tous c'est Pierre vous êtes
bien sur envergure nouvel épisode five
stars aujourd'hui on va parler d'un
meneur de grande taille il est serbe et
pour se faire je suis accompagné de
Lucas et Mathias salut messieurs sal
salut un meneur de grande taille
forcément ça ça intéresse les yeux des
scout NBA et pas que c'est Lucas qui l'a
vu qui a eu la chance de le voir en vrai
de ce jeune homme qui s'appelle Nicolas
topic Lucas qui
est-til niikolas topic c'est d'abord le
fils
d'une légende du basket serbe c'est
c'est leur tenony parkerur à eux
euh mais malgré son sa sa renommée et
ses nombreux
succès son son père a toujours rest été
est toujours resté fidèle à à à ses
valeurs qu'il avait avant de réussir
dans le basket donc c'est un homme
humble et cetera et il a transmis ses
valeurs à à à Nicolas qu'on qu'on
retrouve
a autant sur le terrain que en dehors du
terrain il a commencé au à l'étoile
rouge il a été formé là-bas pour au
final cette année partir au Méga et
c'est réellement le leader de de
l'équipe du méga alors que c'est une
équipe quand
même qui joue qui qui a par exemple là
la semaine dernière ils ont ils sont
bien battu contre l'étoile rougge ils
ont craqué dans les deux dernières
minutes mais c'est vraiment une équipe
qui tient la route et leur leader est en
2004 donc c'est c'est d'autant plus
impressionnant
et et voilà 2004 je crois qu'il fait 2 m
2 m2 si je dis pas de bêtises
ouais alors ça moi je je j'ai regardé
les sites et j'ai un petit peu toutes
les tailles ça va de 2 m2 à m95 donc moi
j'ai j'ai 2,1 là d'accord ah c'est en
2005 en plus désolé ouais 2005 ça va
être un des plus jeunes joueurs à la
prochaine draft il me semble ouais donc
Nikola topic qui que tu asu tu as eu
l'occasion de voir aussi dans un autre
contexte peut-être que tu peux nous en
parler euh cet été
ouais je l'ai vu une première fois avec
Manu euh euh en je crois que c'était en
2021 à l' MT Belgrade que lasv a
remporté d'ailleurs euh donc un contexte
où il était le leader on va dire
euh plus sur le
côté plus le distributeur c'était Lucas
voudragovic la star de cette équipe là
et puis cet été c'était lui réellement
la la tête d'affiche de de l'équipe 18 à
Nietzsche en Serbie donc vraiment
impressionné par son
évolution de de jeu en en finale en 1 an
et puis là je me je me surprends à
vraiment être encore plus impressionné
de le voir faire la même chose qu'
niveau 18 mais face à des pros et et
c'est pas rien donc là il est dans quel
rôle donc tu l'as dit il est au Méga B
max he c'est ça ça pas rechangé de nom
le le club non non je crois que c'est je
crois que c'est ça ah non c'est le
mégaam maintenant
ah du coup c'est donc tu as dit c'est
une équipe qui reste compétitive donc ça
c'est intéressant dans une Lig pro c'est
aussi autre chose qui est intéressant
c'est quoi vraiment son son rôle cette
année dans dans cette équipe là c'est
clairement le leader
c'est c'est lui qui qui remonte la balle
qui organise le jeu qui gueule sur les
joueurs qui font pas leur taf sur les
mecs qui respectent pas le système c'est
lui qui a annonce c'est lui qui gère les
timings franchement il a énormément de
responsabilités pour un pour un genouur
de stage là et si on regarde seulement
le match c'est impossible de dire que
c'est un seulement 2005 il y a une chose
qu'on a pas faite et peut-être qu'on
aurait dû commencer par là c'est parler
de son physique parce que alors oui il
il est grand mais il a il a un physique
assez particulier comment comment tu
peux nous le décrire euh il a un corps
plutôt long il fait 2 M1 et il a une
envergure de c'est un seven footer au
niveau de lambgure donc 213 h il a un
long coup ce qui a fait parler plus
d'un GT
et c'est pas physiquement c'est pas le
joueur le plus sexy sur le terrain euh
il a pas il est pas extrêmement
athlétique il respire pas la
verticalité mais une fois qu'il a la
balle en main et qui et qu'il annonce un
pick and roll là c'est c'est autre
chose ben justement vu que c'est autre
chose on va parler de son ticket
d'entrée pour NBA parce que là on est en
plein dedans j'ai l'impression son son
ticket d'entrée pour la NBA j'ai
toujours parlé de lui en tant que
microave scorer avec ses qualités de
finition au cercle qui m'ont toujours
impressionné mais depuis peu je me je me
surprends à à vraiment le voir en tant
qu'organisateur en NBA il a il a la
vision de jeu il a la qualité de passe
il a le handle il a la taille aussi donc
moi je le vois vraiment dans un ticket
de très bon joueur de pick and roll qui
est capable de finir au cercle qui sera
un très bon lieutenant pour accompagner
une superstar dans une équipe qui joue
ha par rapport à ces qualités tu tu l'as
dit il est très très bon dans la
finition en
cercle je crois que là cette année il y
a une stade qui est complètement absurde
où il est à quasiment 70 % au au
Cercle c'est des c'est des stades de
pivot quoi ouais clairement enfin de
pivot très très bon donc comment il
comment il arrive à à faire ça parce que
comme tu as dit il respire pas la
verticalité ni l'athlétisme vraiment
comment il s'en sort pour moi c'est un
vrai
folant quand tu le regardes sur instat
ou sur les sur les highlights de du méga
tu le vois jouer tu dis mais comment il
fait et quand tu le vois faire ces fras
que dans face à face quoi dans la vraie
vie tu vois vraiment qu'en fait il est
rapide mais il n'a pas du tout l'air il
a une facilité il a un premier pas qui
efface facilement son défenseur donc il
a pas du tout de problème à faire la
différence même si c'est pas l'un des
joueurs les plus rapides ni les plus
athlétiques et une fois qu'il arrive au
cercle il arrive toujours à trouver le
bon timing le bon saut la bonne lecture
des espaces il a un très bon toucher et
aussi sa taille lui permet de monter au
contact avec des intérieurs et de
pouvoir toujours finir euh malgré
l'opposition mais c'est pas un un un mec
qui qui va pouvoir poster tout le monde
à toutv va mais c'est un gars qui va peu
importe ce qui sera au Cercle va réussir
à finir ce c'est quand même
impressionnant même face à des gros
protecteurs de cercle des gros intérieur
Serb à l'ancienne il arrive tout de même
à à finir euh assez facilement on a
parlé euh donc de son jeu offensif euh
on va continuer là-dessus est-ce que
pour toi il a euh il a il a ce tu l'as
dit c'est c'est un il score cette année
il a plus de 15 points par match là en
ligue Adriatique est-ce qui c'est moi
j'ai l'impression que c'est un petit peu
polarisé c'est soit il tire à trois
points soit il tire près du cercle
est-ce qu'il a ce jeu un petit peu à
mi-distance ou pas du tout ou il en a
pas besoin juste je pense que il il doit
avoir un coach qui lui répète que le tir
midistance c'est le tir le moins
efficace parce que comme tu l'as dit il
s'arrête très rarement entre les deux et
soit c'est du tir longue distance soit
soit il va finir IR au cercle il y a pas
de il y a pas d'entre deux même si pour
moi son tir à TR points est encore à à
perfectionner euh mais il y a vraiment
des de très bons flash qui qui
étrangement quand statistiquement si tu
regardes le match tu tu peux dire que
c'est un bon shooter régulier et cetera
mais statistiquement il est seulement à
30 % à 3 points donc est-ce que on peut
me remettre ça sur une mauvaise
sélection de tir ou peut-être que étant
donné que c'est le premier porteur de
balle de son équipe il est rarement en
position prendre des bon tir mais il a
il a il a une palette offensive qui est
plutôt complète mais c'est vrai que
comme tu l'as dit il s'arrête très
rarement euh à mes distance
euh sur sur sa qualité de drible
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire sur ça parce
que c'est important vu que c'est ça
amené à être un porteur de balle c'est
ce qui fait aussi sa force comment il
est son son drible il est il est pas
extravagant il va pas chercher à à en
faire trop il se il fait le bon drible
au bon moment tout est juste dans dans
dans ce qu' fait c'est pas extravagant
c'est pas sexy c'est pas overtime c'est
vraiment il fait ce qu'il faut et et
mine de rien il perd très peu de balles
dans dans le drible sauf quand il seit
embêté par vraiment des petits gardes de
en moins d' 1 M80 et là souvent il lui
pose énormément de problème étant donné
qu'il fait 2 M1 et que son drible est
quand même haut pour des meneurs de
cette taille là mais face à des meneurs
on va dire taille
je pense que ils aont ils auront du mal
à lui prendre la balle en tout cas
Mathias tu l'as vu aussi un peu la
Nikola topic qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
te plaît chez chez ce joueur là bah je
pense que ce qui plaît c'est d'abord son
côté offensif Lucas a très bien parlé
maintenant moi ce que j'aime bien aussi
et c'est plus rare de de le souligner
mais souvent les les prospects en tout
cas NC ont tendance à être des bons
défens ur sur l'homme mais un peu moins
un peu moins loin du ballon et Topit je
trouve que c'est l'inverse forcément il
est limité par ses qualités physiques
pour être très bon sur l'homme mais moi
j'aime beaucoup le le défenseur loin du
ballon il est il est rarement pris il
est rarement pris dans son dos il est
toujours très concentré et je trouve ça
témoigne d'un état d'esprit vraiment
vraiment
important justement vu que tu nous
lances un petit peu sur le côté défense
c'est un petit peu aussi c'est ce qu'il
a à travailler on va dire s est il sera
jamais à mon avis connu pour ses
qualités défensives à l'étage
supérieur comment ça peut se transférer
à ton avis Lucas clairement ouais je je
suis d'accord avec toi mais pour moi
comme l'a dit
Mathias même si sur l'homme il est
limité parce qu'il a un haut centre de
gravité et cetera il a pas la latéralité
d'un d'un d'un pas de
Beverley il a cette envie et cette
vision de jeu qui lui permet de avec son
envergure de venir quand même récupérer
des balles et ne coûter que au final
très peu de points pour quelqu'un qui ne
qui a du mal à défendre sur l'homme donc
clairement il compense tout ça avec son
envie et et et pour être un peu cliché
sa détermination quoi et puis aussi sans
doute un petit peu de cuil basket vu que
ouis clairement ouais vu la lignée
basket dans laquelle il est euh il y a
quelque chose quand même qui est assez
redondant entre guillemets chez lui d'un
point de vue statistique c'est que cet
été là avec les jeunes Serbes il perdent
trois ballons par match là il repèd
encore trois ballons par match euh pour
à chaque fois 5 si pass décisif donc le
ratio assist turnover est plutôt bon euh
elles viennent sur quoi c'est
principalement C ces turnover est-ce que
il y a quelque chose qui revient un
petit peu dans le type de turnover qu'il
a euh Lucas HM souvent c'est à la passe
il va faire une passe ou il va anticiper
quelque chose que son coéquipier ne va
pas faire par exemple une coupe il va
vouloir anticiper la coupe et mettre la
balle dans dans la coupe sauf que son
coier resté à à tris points mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a toujours ces paires de
balles systématiques et qui sont pour
moi pas inquiétant doné son âge et
surtout l'échantillon les minutes qui
passent avec la balle c'est c'est
vraiment impressionnant Oméga toutes les
balles passent par lui et finir avec je
crois qu'il a 35 minutes de de temps de
jeu par moyenne finir avec seulement
trois paires de balles quand tu es le le
porteur de balle principal avec 6,6 ass
de moyenne franchement je trouve ça
impressionnant
ouais parce qu'il est quasiment euh
comme on va utiliser un terme cher Alan
qu'on embrasse d'ailleurs il est
quasiment hocentrique au au Méga en fait
ouais clairement c'est vraiment tout
passe par lui euh et pourtant il est né
en 2005 euh qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
encore donc tu as Paris son foot euh à
trois points tu as dit for justement qu'
était à 30 % est-ce que ça t'inquiète ou
pas plus que ça dans la mécanique est-ce
qu'il y a il y a des choses à revoir
est-ce que par
exemple c'est c'est ces choix sont pas
bon comment on explique ça ou que c'est
peut-être pas forcément non plus un
grand shooter naturellement mais que
c'est quelqu'un à force de travail qui
va pouvoir sanctionner de façon
régulière pour moi c'est c'est sa PIST
de travail principale mais c'est pas
quelque chose qui m'inquiète comme tu
l'as dit je pense qu'avec du travail et
c'est pas c'est pas de ça qui manque la
rigueur et cetera je pense qu' du
travail il sera vraiment en capacité de
sanctionner j'ai envie de le comparer à
un Jamal me au niveau du tir à TR points
et au même âge il a une gestuelle qui
est bien plus on va dire en symbiose
avec lui-même du coup du coup je pense
que c'est pas quelque chose qui va
vraiment l'inquiéter étant donné sa
facilité à aller au cercle et aussi sa
qualité de passe mais je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui va définitivement
travailler dans ces premières années NBA
on on l'a dit hein c'est c'est un joueur
qui a une finition cert qui qui est
exceptionnelle pour autant une main
gauche aussi qui est je trouve moi à
titre personnel que je trouve incroyable
on a l'impression vraiment que le garçon
est en bidex c'est assez rare pour pour
le mentionner tu me dis he C tu es pas
d'accord Luc mais et par contre on le
voit pas trop faire euh en terme de de
de finition on voit pas trop sur des euh
des flotteurs des des choses comme ça
qui sont un petit peu dans l'air du
temps euh au niveau des des finitions
des des des gardes en en NBA
ouais ouais bah après je pense qu'ussi
c'est dû euh dû au joueurs qui rencontre
en en match euh il a je pense que dans
en ligue Adriatique il y a quand même
moins de de pivot euh ultra grand et
athlétique euh mais je pense qu'une fois
qu'il va arriver devant des joueurs
comme ça ça il aura forcément besoin
d'avoir un flotteur un flotteur fort et
efficace quand il pourra pas finir
directement au Cercle main gauche main
droite quoi
is Lucas sur le flotteur c'est et ça
rejoint ce que tu disais au début c'est
qu'il a du mal à s'arrêter
entre finir fort au cercle et tirer de
loin et c'est ça c'est pour moi c'est
quelque chose qui doit travailler à
gérer sa vitesse parce que souvent il y
va et il y va pas pour s'arrêter à
michemin et et faire un flotteur mais
comme l'a dit Mathias quand il va en
quand il va arriver en NBA qu' va
affronter des les pivots avec des
mensurations gargon sues qu' va il va
être obligé de de s'adapter on l'imagine
dans quel rôle notre ami Nicolas topic
dans ses premières années
NBA h dans ses premières années NBA je
le vois bien leader de la de la bench
uni dans une équipe qui qui est prête à
jouer ou euh
organisateur dans une équipe un peu
garbage mais pour moi il a clairement le
potentiel pour être dans une équipe qui
va aller chercher qui va il a le
potentiel pour être dans le 5 majeur
d'une équipe avec des ambitions en tant
qu'organisateur distributeur de balle
facilitateur Mathias toi tu l'imagines
comment à partir du moment donné où je
pense que en tout cas c'est ce qui
annoncé pour l'instant ce sera un haut
choix de
draft il va vraisemblblement arriver
dans une équipe un peu garbage et qui
qui va pas forcément chercher à gagner
donc je pense qu'il aura la possibilité
d'avoir beaucoup de minutes et euh et
souvent les les Européens qui qui
arrivent en NBA souvent non n'ont pas le
temps de jeu et les responsabilités que
a to pitch euh en ligue Adriatique donc
je pense que ça va lui servir et je
pense que il va tout de suite avoir des
des des bonnes responsabilités et ce
serait cool pour son développement
forcément un grand meneur qui vient pas
des États-Unis on a tendance à récemment
à penser forcément à Jos Guidi comme
type de joueur en quoi il il est très
différent de geor Guidi le prospect pour
éviter la comparaison paresseuse on va
dire
h j'avoue que je me suis jamais posé la
question de parce que j'ai pas suivi du
tout Josh
gu forcément ça aide ouais
euh mais je dirais que Josh guidy a plus
tendance à être un poste 2 3 alors que
vraiment topach c'est naturellement et
limite un peu trop qui va s'imposer en
tant que poste 1 alors que Josh Guidi il
y a beaucoup de séquences où il se
décale plus en tant qu'aiilier alors que
je vois mal Topit passer en mode AER
avec les qualités qu'il a et son handle
je dirais que Topit a un meilleur handle
et a moins de capacité physique on va
dire que
J d'ailleurs le r toopach euh je vous
recommande chaudement d'aller le voir
parce qu'il a ce côté très old school
dans sa façon de dribbler avec la tête
forcément il est un coup tu l'as dit
Lucas qui est très haut et euh il est il
est il un côté pas très souple dans le
dans le drible on a l'impression qu'il
est très raide au niveau du buste quand
il drible il a un petit côté basketteur
des années 50 qui drible au rat du sol
il y a un petit côté comme ça exactement
qui qui qui m'amuse beaucoup est-ce que
tu as des infos Lucas sur la malité et
l'attitude du garçon des Intel comme on
dit elle est dans la ligée de son père
c'est pour ça que je vous en ai parlé au
début il a un bon cadre familial son
père a voulu vraiment insister sur ces
valeurs là son père n'a toujours refusé
d'être invité par exemple bon pour
certains c'est rien mais quand on côtoie
des des légendes du basket c'est c'est
rare de de voir des des personnes comme
ça il a toujours refusé d'être invité il
a toujours payé ses abonnements dans son
club d'origine qu'il l'a formé donc il
est il a grandi dans ces valeurs là de
travail de
rigueur de modestie
et c'est vraiment ça pour moi qui a
donné ses qualités de leader parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui est respecté à la
fois sur et en dehors du terrain donc je
trouve que vraiment ça fait la
différence dans un roster si je me mets
à la place d'un GM si je dois choisir
entre un quelqu'un qui a grandi dans
Instagram 15 ans de sa vie et qui arrive
avec un Boulard énorme et Nikola topic
qui sort de Serbie qui a des valeurs
familial de travail et cetera le le le
le choix est vite fait donc franchement
je pense que en ayant eu les
échos familial et cetera familiieux
pardon c'est vraiment ça qui a fait la
différence pour moi entre avec des
joueurs de de sa génération où c'est
c'est comme si c'était une valeur sûre
on sait qu'il va pas avoir un contrat et
commencer à à craquer et à et à voir ses
ses performances baisser donc pour moi
c'est vraiment ça qui qui fait la
différence on a l'impression que dans ce
que tu dis ce qui ressort c'est une
certaine stabilité émotionnelle en fait
ou et avec un cadre qui a été très
marqué et sur lequel il peut se reposer
lui aussi en fait donc ça ser je te
rejoins sur ça le côté rassurant pour
les GM et assez évident on est sur quel
genre de potentiel avec Nikola topic
parce que là on parle quand même si je
fais un petit peu le le résumé de ce
qu'on a dit c'est quand même fort joueur
offensif fort créateur est-ce que on
peut
imaginer vraiment le très très haut
niveau pour pour Nikolas topic où il
sera toujours limité un petit peu par
son son son manque de qualité athlétique
on va dire
j'espère pour lui que ça lui coûtera pas
autant mais pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui
a le potentiel de de vraiment là je
m'enfme peut-être mais c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui a le potentiel de de de
vraiment apporter dans une équipe qui
joue le titre par exemple il il a ce
potentiel là ouais déjà si on arrive
enfin tous les GM aimerai drafter un
joueur capable de jouer au niveau des à
la NBA c'est déjà un super coup
Mathias on est où à quel point sur
Nicola
topic bah on est haut hein Mo je rejoins
que je rejoins ce que dit Lucas dans la
progression dans le meilleur des
scénarios quoi le mec il a quand même eu
18 ans en août dernier et il pose des
stats incroyables déjà pour son âge dans
une ligue qui est quand même une bonne
Ligue en Europe donc forcément vu son
âge il a une mar de progression encore
qui qui paraît assez importante s'il
commence à avoir un un une une vraie
efficacité sur son shoot ça va être une
chose différente en plus et puis je
pense que même s'il est jeune il a déjà
un plancher qui qui est vraiment
vraiment bon est-ce que le scénario
minimal c'est pas 10 ans NBA dont la
moitié du temps titulaire est-ce qu'on
par pas déjà quasiment sûr sur ça si tu
parles de plancher Mathias
euh ouais 10 ans je sais pas mais
franchement c'est c'est pas impossible
moi je moi je crois je crois ça ou Lucas
tu es assez optimiste aussi j'ai envie
d'y croire et j'espère que c'est
son manque de verticalité et son côté
vraiment européen ne va pas lui coûter
trop cher
allez question polémique et qui fera un
petit peu teaser pour d'autes prospect
dont on n pas encore vraiment parlé
est-ce que c'est le meilleur européen de
cette QV
AE AE
aïe
est européen est-ce qu'on peut dire
est-ce que c'est le meilleur ah si tu me
demandes si c'est le meilleur joueur qui
joue en Europe oui
ouais en Europe
oui et je pense même le meilleur
européen je pense en vrais va se finir
cet épisode sur niikol top qui a vous
l'avez compris pas mal de fans dans
notre équipe envergure il est temps pour
moi de vous rappeler aussi que de nous
suivre sur les les réseau les réseaux
sociaux pardon sur X notamment comme on
dit hésitez pas aussi à nous dire ce que
ce que vous aimez ce que vous aimez
moins on est là aussi pour échanger il y
a aucun problème sur ça on vous souhaite
à tous bah des bonnes fêtes parce qu'on
est encore dans la période des fête et
puis on vous dit à très vite bye bye
salut
[Musique]